please settle down settle down
yes the rumors are true the boy is still
missing I know we all want him back but
we still have a handful of leads I will
now go to the press for any questions
yes all right shut Ripley MSNBC is the
boy's father a suspect we cannot comment
on the suspect list at this time yes
hey Matt how's it going Bob Newman
BuzzFeed news right I should say it's
right now we are treating blogs as news
now so they are loud in the press room
go ahead yeah we just say that this case
is something only kids from the 90s
would understand no cookies and cash
from your lifestyle blog my coffee is
too hot will you blow on it next
question hunter chuckman alaskan salmon
daily does this case have anything to do
with Alaskan salmon no Branson
Rothschild shippers delight tumblr.com
okay are you and the boy's father
crushing on each other
are we crushing on each other I don't
know what no no we're not crushing but I
have pages of fan art that would suggest
otherwise so this is doesn't matter
about feint we're talking about this is
guys we need serious questions it's a
serious situation see more glass with
banana fish dot boink
I represent an online humorist muga zine
and caters mostly to widows and
basements what does your fault I don't
know what that I don't know how to
answer that Hey
James Franco sir James Franco's
instagrams Franco this is what I'm
talking about all right a child is
missing I need serious questions please
hunter chuckman does the case have
anything to do with ours consume no more
dead cops from the Dark Knight I won't
Hollywood cast Jessica Biel any mom
continuity calm this lady is now sitting
where that lady was sitting earlier your
old splorch and doc big booty milfs dot
hell yeah
fingerblast go inside job listen to me I
understand that this is where the press
has headed but if you guys can't take a
situation seriously how are we supposed
to take you seriously now does anybody
in this room have an actual question
what is it
where was the boy last seen thank god
you're here the boy was last seen at the
sunshine cafe eating a I want to make
sure I get this right
bagel with Alaskan salmon